if we could change one thing with our
culture I think of great start
maybe not the end-all be-all but what
would be encouraging people to do the
thing that they love that they feel like
they were put on this earth to do you
really need to be all about execution
because great ideas they don't matter
great ideas are a dime a dozen ideas are
cheap and abundant and mean nothing
unless they're actualized get good
grades you'll get a good job then you'll
work for a company for 40 years you get
the gold watch and you'll have a great
retirement that's just fundamentally not
true need motivation watch atop tenant
belief nation what's up at 7:00 my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from wanting to go to
medical school to becoming a world-class
photographer and creating an online
education system for creators called
creative live he's Chase Jarvis and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success enjoy good to me pleasure thanks
for saying hi what was your name when
you do
Ivan Carmichael
help entrepreneurs have a pop the
YouTube channel almost 2,000 subscribers
basically wisdom advice launch Peru
trying to grow the business
sweet I'm blogging today so I'll make
sure you're in the blog yeah thanks a
lot for same height and I appreciate
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be great at your craft being
great at your craft is a requirement
yeah
yeah and I'm not I wouldn't suggest that
you stop that you don't try and get work
or hustle or do all those other things
while you're coming up because that's a
part of the game and that's you know
Gary Vee is a big advocate for hustling
and so you got to hustle your whole way
but being great at your craft actually
matters yeah yeah and and having like
the camera is like an extension of my
arm and you think about it I have used
the probe golf analogy I don't know why
I not crazy about golf but those guys
have to again women have to stand up on
the tee and hit the ball down the middle
because that's what they're paid to do
doesn't matter if it's raining sunny
weenie if there's ten people watching or
ten million they're paid yet the ball
down the middle and as an artist you're
paid to make and as an entrepreneur
you're paid to deliver the the ROI to
the shareholders and as a wrestler
you're paid to win or like whatever your
thing is you have to be great at your
craft in order to I think achieve so
there's this 10,000 hours hardcore the
folks that I think are great whether
they're hacking the system and doing it
in ten hours
right or 10,000 that is I think people
want to skip that step
yeah I get I get you know for every
email that I get about the craft of
writing yeah I get a thousand about how
to market books on the ratio is all
wrong yep so no I would agree with that
and so elect its overlooked like I just
want to be this awesome fashion
photographer and hang out with like
awesome you know beautiful people and
crazy locations and it's like dude you
got a beat like you actually pick up a
camera and get good that first and then
you might be able to do you know part
rule number two do what you love Michael
asks why did you give up medicine to be
a pro photographer to be clear I never
gave up medicine I hit the ripcord the
eject the launch then whatever I aborted
I dropped out I quit specifically
because I was chasing something that
somebody else wanted for me something
that not just my parents not just my
family but I felt like what's
I eighty expected of me I literally
remember asking people like oh what
should I do when I grow up was your
experimenting and thinking about this as
a young person and like well you're
smart you get good grades you're hard
worker you should be a doctor because
that's what people who are hardworking
and smart do be a doctor or lawyer you
make good money and like literally that
was a societal frame that I was given
I'm done with this water I don't know
why I still hold onto that water and I
think that's horrible it's catastrophic
if we could change one thing with our
culture I think of great start maybe not
the end-all be-all but what would be
encouraging people to do the thing that
they love that they feel like they were
put on this earth to do that's what I
did and and believe me I'm making it
sound like it was easy it was so hard I
spent years and years doing what other
people wanted me to do and I had to grow
a pair and do a lot of soul-searching in
here and figure out that they figure out
what I wanted to do and then be have the
the heart to do that thing and I feel
like I'm a very confident hard-working
person who had a lot going up you know
middle-class upbringing I can't say that
I had this child had built with struggle
and it was hard for me to break through
the clutter and do the thing that I was
supposed to do so for those folks who
were disadvantaged came from a single
family home or single-parent home or God
there's a million challenges I can only
imagine how hard it is so long answer
but it was very hard for me to not
pursue medicine but dear God if I could
change one thing I would help people
find their passion rule number three
take action I'm concerned because so
many of us we and I'll include myself in
there sometimes we dip into this this
perpetual cycle of planning rather than
doing and I'm seeing a lot in our
community I'm hearing about it so I'm
even experiencing it I I want to remind
us all a reminder to me but also to you
that doing is what matters now you know
I I want to explain maybe I'll talk
about a couple of points one I'm not
suggesting that you do know
and what I am suggesting is that you do
way less planning because the planning
is the thing that can act as a crutch it
it's motion but no progress
you are whiteboarding you're watching
another TED talk or maybe I'm watching
another one of these videos so I'm not
trying to disincentivize you from
engaging in contact content like this
and less it's actually keeping you from
doing the thing that you want to do or
that you need to do or that you're
dreaming of rather than just planning it
so that's kind of the the first thing
the second thing that I wanted to share
is that what's the ratio of sort of like
strategy to doing and if you're not
operating in this like 90 percent doing
10% strategy world you're doing it wrong
you really need to be all about
execution because great ideas they don't
matter
great ideas are a dime a dozen ideas are
cheap and abundant and mean nothing
unless they're actualized and all of the
planning like you need to put things out
in the world that people can see or feel
or touch or or interact with because
otherwise it's up here and things that
are up here they're just not worth that
much in the world of making and creating
and trying to change and impact the
world
from that point of view so you know you
need to be in that 90 to 10 ratio 90%
doing 8 to 10 percent making rule number
four be different assuming you're great
at your craft that you flex your muscles
enough to to be recognized as you have
mastery of the thing that at that point
it becomes how can you be different not
just better and whether that's the way
you see the world whether that's the
project that you're working on whether
it's what your aspirations like
listening to talk about Travis from uber
he's a friend and he came to me you and
he'd had some initial success in San
Francisco and he said I wanna you know
this service to Seattle can you help me
some people and I was like I didn't know
what you're working on like talk to me
about it but and the the capability the
capacity for thinking different and
thinking big was so clear with Travis
that it's there's sort of this desire to
want to be a part of that movement and
in order to you know you've probably
heard the saying also that it's hard to
get weird going if you don't know where
you want to go right if you just walk in
the woods you know you if you don't have
a destination that's probably you know
you're not gonna arrive at that
destination so it is a matter of how can
I you know and also the Apple slogan
think different like it really is about
different and standing out standing out
is one way thinking big is another way
that's why I collapse it all into how do
you be different not just better because
at the very top pro golfers or like
musicianship the the difference between
the best and the next best is like it
can't even measure it but who's doing
their own thing who has a vision that's
radically different and they see the
world tour lens that no one else sees
that is what people can notice and say
oh my gosh I had a vision of you know
one of the things I did was create the
first iPhone app that shared photos to
social networks it was called the best
camera a year and a half before
Instagram and path and all that stuff it
was radical for me as a professional
photographer who had you know hundreds
of thousands of dollars in gear and
traveled all over the world for the
apples and the Nikes to take pictures to
say I believe in this device this iPhone
to take pictures because it's the best
camera is the one that's with you and
that was radical so that was that was a
different thing and I think the same
thing applies to the folks at home what
is it that you really care about and
what's a lens that you have on the world
that comes from in here that is
different ruler five my personal
favorite practice creativity what do I
do to get out of a funk one I get into
adventures I stop focusing on the funk
and start focusing on living because
living actually influences the things I
make and do so I like try and set the
funk down and go out and live
specifically a
another thing is I go into the practice
of creating which is I literally sort of
booked time to be creative and that
usually over a period of time if you're
sort of um you know I spend an hour to
walk around taking pictures sketching
painting drawing watching films those
are the things that when practice that
creativity that this little spark that
you do from actually just forcing
yourself to take a picture often will
create more creativity that's a
scientific fact that creates it I think
it's mark rongkhun at the University of
Georgia
creativity begets creativity rule number
six develop good habits one of the
reasons I wanted to talk about habits
because I think habits are critical to
change one of the problems that I hear
people say oh man I want to achieve some
goal or change the concept of change is
big and sort of sloppy and amorphous
what habits do in contrast is habits put
that change into very very small steps
and the way I'd make change in my life
is through making a list of habits such
that if I did all of these habits every
day there's no way that I couldn't
actually have that change affected we're
heading in the new year a lot of people
think about the thing that they want to
be or become and I think the research
says that after eight days ninety
percent of the people have given up on
their goals for the year to me that's
nuts what do you need to do in order to
not have that be you that's very simple
what you want to do is not have some
abstract thing out in the world that you
want to accomplish what you want to have
is a series of habits habits are how you
affect change
in very very small steps rule number
seven get more sleep I went for ten
years with an average of five to six
hours of sleep I felt like it was
genetic and I felt like I had a ton of
energy until something happened and that
thing that happened was I was totally
crushed about two years ago I'd been
burning into both ends working 20 hours
a day not getting any sleep I went to
Hawaii and I said you know I'm just
gonna like I'm gonna have zero schedule
on vacation
I slept 14 hours a day for like six days
straight and I felt completely different
than I had
for the previous like six eight weeks
that I've been burning at both ends now
starting about a year ago I shared a
tracking my sleep and I aim to stay in
bed for eight hours a day I can tell you
that I am a definitively way smarter way
nicer more in touch with my creative
side way more in touch with my intellect
and I'm just a better human when I have
more sleep rule number eight go after
your dreams that thing inside you that
you want to do that's the thing that you
should do and chances are there's a
story that you're telling yourself about
why you can't or why it's hard and if
you can step back just for a second
whether if you're meditation or
self-awareness or actually just
listening to the words and then walking
away from this video and like think like
what really is keeping me from doing
that oh I've got a mortgage okay do I
need to be in that big house can i
downsize oh it's my kids well you're
certainly not gonna like the kids aren't
gonna go live on the street so can you
sit down with the family and say look at
I really want to pursue this how can we
mitigate the risk like are you are you
proactively doing those things because
at the end of the day what I found
across the board having ultimately been
a career counsellor to millions of
people is that the distance between
where you are right now and where you
want to be living whatever life that is
it's much shorter than you think it is
you wake up and we've got that 3:00 a.m.
crocodile brain that's telling us how
bad we're doing and how far away
everything is and how hard everything is
but if you stepped away from that and
just did an honest assessment and what
I've done as few steps as you could the
distance is always shorter than you
think it is I think it's fair to say
that that there are a lot of barriers
between you and that thing but as soon
as you realize that those barriers are
there to keep everybody else out
it'll for you to go after your your
dreams rule number nine immerse yourself
in your industry
Eden Chavez asks who is your first
commercial client and how did you score
that job I did a shoot for a company
called Hart skis which doesn't even
exist anymore if you're like a freestyle
mogul bumper you remember these skis
from like 90s anyway and I got that
because I was immersed in the ski
industry someone who worked for Hart
skis saw that I was taking great
pictures and it had their product in and
they said why wouldn't it be cool if I
put you together with this athlete so
the answer is Hart skis the the why or
the how is because I immersed myself in
the industry that I knew a lot about and
gave me passion and I was known I became
known as a photographer in that world if
you do those same things you can get
commercial jobs too and rule number ten
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is wake up and if you heard
Kuban recently came out and said that
it's not programming jobs at the jobs of
the future because all those will be
automated because when programming can
program for itself what do you need you
need creativity you need ideation the
ability to differentiate not just on
math because it's not all about math
it's math plus the human element so
creativity is actually the most valuable
thing in the next generation it is the
first time in the history of the world
where those systems that have been in
place that were quote the safe bets go
to college you know get good grades
you'll get a good job then you'll work
for a company for 40 years you get the
gold watch and you'll have a great
retirement that's just fundamentally not
true a the school systems changing being
you know it's leaving behind so many
people B employment there's gonna be I
think 53 million Americans are gonna
have a side hustle by 2020 and the
four-year university is not at all set
up to accommodate that not accommodate
it sounds like it's being graceful to
deal with that and if our parents had
one job we will have five the next
generation will have five jobs at the
same time and if you think along those
that those paradigms all of the old
systems are completely inadequate and
that is why creative live exists that is
why that your you will learn an infinite
amount of skills over the next you know
X number of years in your life in a way
that's much different than the way you
learn 10 or 15 years ago and learning is
the new sort of master paradigm it's the
first time in the history of the world
that the safe thing is now the riskiest
thing you can do and if you're not
paying attention to this stuff
like you need to wake up I don't know if
you read the headlines lately but and
you know it's it shouldn't be a fear
thing it should maybe we change that
it's like what an amazing time it is
where we have access to this knowledge
where the it doesn't cost a million
dollars creativeLIVE has a free option
and there's so many other learning sites
you just got freaking YouTube like what
are you doing what's the next thing for
you that is going to keep you on that
path that I referenced earlier
now I've got three very special bonus
clips from chase for you around how to
be a good storyteller how to start small
and how to meditate but before that I
want to know what did you guys learn
from this chase has so much wisdom to
drop I've learned a lot from the guy I'm
a fan of his channel I would love to
learn from you from the 10 points here
what did you absorb that you're going to
apply somehow to your life or your
business leave it on counts below
looking forward to hear what you have to
say thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clips
I think there's a belief that people who
are successful either they can sell
themselves really well and they're
natural at it like I was a natural hard
worker
yeah but not and not a gifted like
positioner and seller and that was all
learned in the same way that some of the
stuff we talked about earlier was
learned the art of negotiation the art
of position yourself in a marketplace of
telling your story that that is that is
not at least it wasn't an eight for me
yeah and I had to learn that so there's
another belief that oh if you have
talent then you just actually you're
just are successful which is a total
horrible Ryan holiday talks a lot about
this you have to like what I mean I did
someone else's quote but it's like
there's nothing more common than what is
it the unsuccessful man of talent or
something like that
yeah decided they're tired for sure cuz
there's so many of them that idea of
once you make something that if it's
great it will just be discovered is
totally fiction yeah the people that I
know that are successful soon as it's
done the making part then it's about
packaging and frankly the narrative like
being a good storyteller is mission
critical to having your idea project
plan work vision company whatever spread
you said being able to tell a good story
is another thing that people overlook so
to that topic of intuition we've got
people in the chat talking about some of
the things that they want to do but
they're afraid I'm wondering for you how
did you maybe like in the earliest days
because it's a muscle that you build and
you start getting used to it as it works
out then it's easy to trust it again but
in those early days when you're not
sharing your pressures and bills and
family may not support you and all of
you know all that stuff that hog
referred the artists and creators have
to go to how do you for that first time
get the confidence to trust the
intuition muscle well first of all it's
important to know that we all have those
things and even people that you look
look at and say Mike there's no way that
person has a fearful bone in their body
people are either so ego driven or so
like willing to do whatever it takes
that is a learned behavior
that is not something that you just walk
out those yeah whatever sixth grade with
it's something that you get to you get
comfortable with and then you know so
the follow-on is well then how do you
get comfortable and for me and again a
pattern that I saw and you know friends
like you know Tim Ferriss and Gary Vee
and and Swiss Miss and others was that
they started small there was the the
risks were small and you got comfortable
with putting yourself out there you know
for Gary Vee was selling baseball cards
he'd sit there and he'd you know try and
hustle someone for an extra 50 bucks on
this you know this I don't know a Ron
Jaworski card from nineteen you know 78
or something and and then you learn
about you know the dynamic between fear
and being rejected and being accepted
and you do that enough times in a low
weight circumstance and you can get
comfortable for me it was the same way
it started out with putting out sharing
with photographs and saying yeah first
of all when everyone else around me I
dropped at a medical school build on a
career in professional soccer and
dropped out of a PhD in philosophy to
become a photographer if you don't think
my parents were just totally like
freaked out by that you're crazy you
know they were and and yet the first
step was like actually calling myself a
photographer saying that I wanted to do
this and that was a big you know
overcoming a bunch of fear there what
when you think about like what's the
real fear well I'm probably not gonna
you know get shunned from just saying I
want to be a photographer so I said it
quietly at first and a little bit louder
and then I started showing pictures and
then one picture into picture and you
can see without me excavating the whole
you know the whole timeline how you
could literally develop the muscle as
you refer to it as so starting small
failing on the regular achieving some
degree of success even if it's only
amongst your peer group and then trying
to expand that and that's where the
10,000 hours comes from that you've all
heard about it's because you have to
develop that muscle over so much time
that that's where that it's it's that's
10,000 hours of not just math
from your craft but being willing to put
it out there I think Tim Ferriss and I
who Tim is a lovely hand we've been
friends for a long time
first of all a it was I remember a
couple of conversations about isn't this
edge this like at your core you've got a
fire in your belly you're driven you
mentioned sort of type a hard-charging
whatever words that you would associate
that you start to believe your own story
that that is what has created your
success and we don't stop or pause we're
unwilling to part with that even long
enough to see if that narrative at self
narrative is true because if we stop
that hard-charging type a a grow you
know undercurrent will we lose a step
what were those two steps well we fall
from the position that we've worked so
hard to get ourselves into I remember
specifically execs it and talking to Tim
and he was feeding me this line I was
like all those things you said I thought
the exact and I can only say what my
truth is I can't say what your truth is
Tim but just give it a shot
how about what if you were able to think
about that thing that you thought was
propelling you is actually an anchor
that is the thing that is keeping you
down or small or or at some percentage
of your potential rather than in their
way around try and tell yourself that
narrative just long enough for you to
take a break from your aggro
hard-charging type-a life and you know
there's any one of these types of
meditation I have a dustier Tim and and
I found Transcendental Meditation TM TM
org as one that was sticky for me Tim
you know ended up gravitating to that
same thing and when you are able to make
that switch you realize as I did I think
as Tim did that and when you say switch
me switch in the narrative yes what's
the narrative and change your daily
habits such that meditation as a part of
your day-to-day for me
it I was quickly easy to see that oh my
god this is actually it's like a rocket
it's like a booster because now
everything around me is happening in
slow motion I don't get fire
and it was a fundamental change in the
way that I sort of interacted with the
world and I don't it's like I don't want
to preach meditation because it's not
for everybody if there is just if you
read tools for titans tim's book of
course the number one correlated thing
across all those people some sort of
mindfulness practice now you're ready
yeah I'm gonna be the [ __ ] that says
this for everybody there you go cuz I'm
just taking it from a neurological
perspective you go like purely from a
neurological perspective because I know
what's happening right you're tapping
into the parasympathetic nervous system
you call me down the sympathetic like
it's just it's biochemistry right so if
you believe in biochemistry then give it
a shot I'm a huge advocate I try not to
sell it too hard because anytime
someone's trying to sell you something
it feels you know feels inauthentic but
it's just given me a lot of joy raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people need passion
[Music]
not one drop of most self-worth depends
on Europe it's suppose to mean I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details